but anyway lot sure era had this very
dark history of these rubber atrocities
while we rolled in there and immediately
there began the unfolding over just
about a three week period I mean a very
short length of time from the 27th of
February 1971 until the 22nd of March so
a period of just under four weeks it was
like the doorway was standing open all
rational expectation had to be put
behind it was as though our whole lives
had built to this moment and what was
what we thought was a quest for an
obscure orally active tryptamine drug it
turned out it was more as though
something something which had been with
us from the cradle actually lured us to
this extremely remote place where there
was no way out no radio no communication
of any sort lured us to this place to
then begin this series of unfolding
ideas and these ideas that were released
in that three-week period are basically
all I've ever worked with I haven't had
an original thought since March of 1971
it's just been endless recension and
reworking of what happened there well
what happened was
you